salut à tous et bienvenue dans le
magazine de votre université et véhicule
et vous au programme de ce numéro une
rétrospective complète sur la journée
festive d'étudiantes le festival balance
la sauce zoom ensuite sur les actualités
marquantes de cette rentrée à travers
les news enfin le portrait de maxime
turbo ski en étudiant du le russe il est
diplômé en management de l'éco
innovation et double champion de france
universitaire en haltérophilie et tout
de suite le micro-trottoir très bon
moi j'étais en prépa donc l'ambiance est
totalement différente là c'est plus
décontracté on va dire que tu as plus de
temps déjà et
et plus les moyens de faire
enfin autre chose des activités donc ça
s'est bien passé tranquille les preuves
sont sympas et prennent le temps de nous
expliquer donc une bonne ambiance
donc c'est la relation prof élève qui
est vraiment intéressante par rapport au
lycée où les profs tu plais tu peux leur
parler vraiment comme enfin il ya une
relation dominant-dominé c'est vraiment
tu cherches tu cherches à réussir et
c'est tout ce que j'ai apprécié la façon
que les administratifs de l'université
et les profs se comporte à la façon que
se portent avec les les élèves cediv ans
passent pas comme au lycée où tout est
mort et quoi personne vous avez
surveillants que disent elles en cours
ou quoi ben ça c'est la liberté quoi
cette journée vient de l'enseignement
que nous avons pu tirer lors de la
journée pour nous avons organisé l'année
dernière pour les 20 ans de l'université
nous avons essayé de développer
d'insister sur le fait que cette journée
devait être un festival pour les
étudiants une journée consacrée
exclusivement aux étudiants et aux
associations agrées par l'université ce
festival balance la sauce a lieu le 27
septembre sur le campus de saint quentin
en yvelines et le 4 octobre sur le
campus des sciences à versailles le gros
de cette journée c'est le village
associatif où toutes les associations
agrées de lui et ce qu sont présentes
une autre perspectives et possibilités
pour cette journée c'est l'intégration
des étudiants c'est à dire que ça leur
permet de se rencontrer de rester un
petit peu pour passer un bon moment
avec les animations que nous proposons
ou avec les associatifs c'est
véritablement un moyen de renforcement
de la cohésion étudiante pour
l'université
le plus gros de ce festival c'est le
village associatif mais c'est aussi des
animations musicales avec le groupe
haier reggae c'est aussi les stands
alimentaires le stand de crêpes
les stands de smoothie et bien entendu
le partenariat avec le pouce qui propose
un panier repas unique pour tous les
étudiants
pour la partie midi de cette journée de
cette manifestation nous pouvons trouver
un instant de huy où les étudiants
peuvent s'amuser en jouant à des jeux
plutôt interactif nous avons les combats
de sumos aussi et enfants des tournois
sportifs au que c'est assez sympa pour
les associations étudiantes parce que ça
permet de se faire connaître
2 pourquoi pas de permettre de
rencontrer des étudiants qui sont pas au
courant
forcément de ce qui se passe dans la vie
universitaire au niveau des associations
et ça permet pourquoi pas de recruter
des futurs adhérents ou des futurs
membres actifs alors s'investir dans le
milieu associatif c'est très important
pourquoi parce que et d'un c'est une
valorisation du cv deuxièmement c'est
surtout de mal aux relations sur le plan
humain c'est rencontrer connaître des
personnes de nouvelles personnes des
gens qui ne sont pas forcément dans sa
filière et ensuite sur le côté festif
parce que évidemment c'est plus que
c'est plutôt sympa ce de faire la fête
tous ensemble et de se réunir et de
s'unir sur des projets caritatifs
culturel et cetera
pour commencer ce tour d'actu on se rend
tout d'abord à paris dans les locaux
d'arts et métiers paristech ou notre
école d'ingénieurs liste y organisait la
21e édition du symposium romane pendant
cinq jours des chercheurs en robotique
du monde entier ont pu présenter leurs
travaux sur les interactions homme robot
on s'intéresse à la communication de la
forme verbale et non verbale on
s'intéresse aussi bien à la psychologie
on s'intéresse aux jeux à l'éducation à
l'apprentissage
c'est en fait un public extrêmement
divers qui participent à cette
conférence qui fait son intérêt son
charme
la star des robots présenté au public
était incontestablement robonaut 2 un
robot développé par la nasa et présents
dans la station spatiale internationale
m
retour maintenant sur nos campus où nos
étudiants de médecine ont découvert à la
rentrée leur tout nouveau bâtiment d'une
superficie de 13 mille quatre cents
mètres carrés
il accueille notamment trois
amphithéâtres 10 salles d'enseignement
et près de 7400 mètres carrés de bureaux
de recherche et de laboratoires
les étudiants de médecine se sont
d'ailleurs félicités pour le travail
fourni lors de l'année universitaire
précédente au cours de l'habituelle
cérémonie de clôture qui a eu lieu à
l'orangerie du château de versailles
c'est un grand honneur j'étais un petit
peu impressionné parce qu'il y avait
tous les professeurs que j'ai pu
rencontrer pendant mon cursus
c'est le fait que qui est très dynamique
que je savais pas autant dynamique
d'ailleurs je suis en train de m'en
rendre compte
ce qui est bien c'est que pour les
étudiants il ya plein de terrain de
stage différent parce que plein
d'hôpitaux différent et ça c'est un gros
plus par rapport aux facs ofac intra
muros aux facs parisiennes intra muros
le campus de versailles accueillait
quant à lui les cinquièmes journées de
l'association nationale des services
tice et audiovisuelle cette association
a pour objectif principal de favoriser
l'intégration de la pédagogie par le
numérique
parmi les différentes thématiques
abordées lors de ces journées
l'innovation pédagogique au service du
handicap qu'il faut leur offrir les
mêmes services que les autres étudiants
et que ce soit au niveau des ressources
pédagogiques que ce soit au niveau des
installations dont les amphis pour que
un aveugle puisse avoir les mêmes
chances de réussite qu'un autre étudiant
dans le reste de l'actu de ce mois ci
l'université a mis en place différents
services pour accueillir ces nouveaux
étudiants rentrée solennelle espace
d'accueil multiservices ou encore un
séminaire d'intégration pour nos
étudiants étrangers savon et la
connaissance des beaucoup de personnes
erasmus et l'acide et l'afrique de
l'amérique aussi et l'europe et on a
partagé beaucoup de choses
et alors je crois que c'est un bonne
idée d'organiser cet événement
l'université alors moi c'est parfait
c'est tout pour les news de ce mois ci
n'oubliez pas que vous pouvez suivre
toute l'actualité de l'université sur
notre facebook notre twitter ou sur
www.beille.fr
manille
thébaux à vis à vis de news
l'autre jean marc compétition les
embrouilles this we have a nice en panne
entre les gouttes
merci d'avoir regardé ubs q vous rendez
vous dès le mois prochain pour un
nouveau numéro
ok